da allora ferma tifosi
bravo
[Musica]
aiuto aiuto o c'è chi infatti che state
qui
è già arrivato da rivolto sappiamo che
sappiamo
[Musica]
perché di questo
aiuto aiuto oggi qualche starnuto
mi sto prendendo per scappare
ci sono nascosta o non mi troverà mai o
forse sì o forse meglio scappare via
[Musica]
a chi sta qui perché non mi stia
seguendo via via via
scappiamo
ma che cosa stai facendo o no vi
semplice andò qua dentro
un ruolo di d'uscita
dove posso andare
ad un'altra piacere da qui hai capito
fabrici
no no no va bene io sto bene anche qui
ha lasciato anche una sedia per me
grazie sì molto gentile aspetterò quindi
essere liberato allora perché dopo prova
a scappare spero tanto che anita mi
troverà mi libererà dai banchi che mi
chiuso ha detto
guarda che se vengo lì
chissà dov'era dita ciao ragazzi
vitale è stato imprigionato da hugh ma
chi devo riuscire a liberarlo per
liberarlo dovrò risolvere tutti gli
enigmi qua al parco giochi avete visto
dove siamo stiamo al tatà parti grazie
ad da forti per averci ospitato di nuovo
il posto ideale se volete organizzare le
vostre feste di compleanno eventi e
bellissimo presto devo sbrigarmi a
trovare tutti gli indizi e tutti i
meccanismi per sbloccare vitale prima
che dilaghi
non so se a chi va chi vuole mangiare
vitale comunque ho con me il mio libro
storie paurose che mi proteggerà o
proposito è ora disponibile in tutte le
librerie online voi l'avete preso ce
l'avete già scrivetelo nei commenti
iniziamo subito dobbiamo liberare
evitare il prima possibile se non avete
ancora lasciato un bivio se lascio che
mi piace qua sotto perché s'è fatto
vedere aggiunge il 20 mila vi piazza e
tornerà è guardata parti a fare un altro
video
questo seguitemi c'è qualche meccanismo
qua innanzitutto dobbiamo trovare il
globo pack così possiamo sbloccare tutti
i vari meccanismi e se per caso a chi
walking inseguirà userò il libro e poi
vedrete come prezzo
andiamo
a
dire liberarmi
italo resisti lì nella prigione con aghi
luoghi anzi ti eri impegnato a chi
guardi così almeno non verrà qua a
prendermi ho bisogno di un po di tempo
per trovare tutte le soluzioni ancora
non ho trovato il grappa da qua devo
salire sopra allo scivolo mi sono
ricordata di mettere i calzini
antiscivolo
vediamo se ci riesco uffici volo
o no ogni volta salirà qua dallo scivolo
e difficilissimo ma non posso perdere
tempo qua ha cercato di salita allo
scivolo devo trovare un'altra strada
libera io topi con i tuoi poteri credo
che il libro non abbia poteri
antiscivolo vabbè andiamo in un'altra
strada presto
[Musica]
scattava tema che è arrivato qua è
presto detto
aiuto aiuto aiuto a dio voti alla sopra
noi dobbiamo passare da quel passaggio
lo giuro vedete qua è un altro passaggio
per non passare dallo scivolo
può sempre aspettare che la tv a chi
vota pia
speriamo che evita le lodi stranka avete
visto quanto è oggi le anche i guai che
riesce arrampicarti ovunque e poi e
silenzioso quindi potrebbe spuntare
fuori all'improvviso da qua
ho sentito un rumore
forse andato via vediamo se non c'è vera
su ok ora possiamo proseguire nel nostro
percorso e cercare il gran pack andiamo
passiamo da qua
spero che il grand funk sia qua sopra
altrimenti senza il grappa che non posso
risolvere gli enigmi chissà come sarà
vitale presso presto ecco qua siamo
nell'altra area prima di vuoti ha
eseguito vitale 4 ma ora viene rinchiuso
dall'altra parte però forse quali sono
trovare qualcosa visto che è passato a
di waqif che quasi lo scivolo ma non
riuscirò salita
ma vediamo che c'è qualcosa da scott a
poco fa non c'è niente non so se passare
qua oppure salire sopra allo scivolo
anche se probabilmente non ci riesce
e ho toccato qualcosa con i miei piedi
guardate guardate
però non ho nessuna delle baghino nella
mano blu nella mano rossa e quindi in
realtà non me ne faccio niente prima e
meglio che trovo le mani e
[Musica]
così è quello di dover un le mani potrà
utilizzarle presto alla ricerca delle
mani ok ragazzi ho appoggiato il grappa
qua ora proverò salire sopra vi
ricordate che vidal e stava scappando in
quel tubo arancione giallo profonda re
lima gari troverò qualcosa
il libro sembra indicare proprio là
sopra andiamo
sbrighiamoci
sento dei rumori strani di sentito anche
voi
spero che non ci sia più fuochi o che
seguissi qua
[Musica]
all improvvisa voglia di scendere non
continuare a salire la sopra da dove far
bene vitale dopo un bar e
non fatto più rumore forse è andato via
speriamo ci sia la mano qua o quella blu
quella rossa
non vedo niente ancora
c'è chi
sta dormendo
non so come sia possibile non avevo mai
visto a di luoghi dormire forse in
trent'anni o anche non lo so normale
come noi mangia dorme va in bagno
non voglio immaginarmi queste cose ma
chi sta proteggendo qualcosa di prezioso
importante che abbiamo il libro con noi
per proteggerci
c'è la mano ha detto ho trovato non è un
blog
è vivo ragazzi ho trovato lavoro blu
tutto grazie al libro che mi ha portato
qua ora non manca solo la mano rossa
non riesce a passare il libro creato uno
scudo in libertà
abbiamo scoperto è sbloccato un altro
potere del libro traccia di armi niente
piccolo libro con me vado a prendere la
mano
[Musica]
eccola qua ma l'ho presa non so perché
ma si sta bene dentro questo tubo e così
il rilassante e come se avessi
improvvisamente dimenticato che c'è un
pupazzo malefico che mi sta inseguendo
spiegarvi ok ragazzi sono tornata quando
ho preso il gra bach ora carichiamolo
con la nostra mano blu
siamo prontissimi a tirare la barra blu
che faccia da chi no penso che la
dovremo usare per qualche puzzle però
sarebbe divertente di tirarla in faccia
l'importante filo sempre il libro con me
che vi proteggerà presto cerchiamo il
puzzle da risolvere le per aprire la
prossima area brani da brava hai fatto a
prendere la mano blu
guarda che per sbloccare il cancello
devi premere quello li guarda lo
guardano
io sono qui tanto oppure a seria con la
figlia ti posso essere qui e fare il
tifo per te margherita fu pulsante
dunque il cancello ok vado subito
vediamo dove questo pulsante blu premi
il pulsante blu col amano più brava roma
guardate ecco il pulsante blu devo
minarlo con la mano blu forse aprirà
quel cancello di cui stava parlando
vitale e non so questa troveremo là
dentro forse la mano rossa speriamo 3 2
ma
avete sentito
il cancello 6 bloccato presso andiamo
prendiamo la mano rossa e poi forse
riusciremo a liberare vita aspetta
ricarichiamo nel caso che incontra
magicamente
vita
ho preso preso no non ho preso niente
volevo dire che ho sbloccato il pulsante
che mi hai detto quindi adesso potrebbe
vendere sembravano uno scatto visto più
ed è rimasta cielo o torna subito sì sì
mi raccomando non mangiarti la sedia o
no però se tu trovi qualcosa del
francese porta ma non tanta foga ma
spero pochi la senza mangiare aspetto
che ci penso
variamo
scritto vede concentrino
dovevo essere umano qua
e che cos'è questo è
che cos'è uno specchio che fa apparire
più brutti ma va beh guardate a stancare
i gestori stai dalla parte non
consideriamo ci importa
che c'è proprio vedere se lo specchio
mappa dire del cibo la smette di
guadagnino specchio ci sono dei funghi
velenosi
mi dispiace per tempo mi sono benvenuti
quindi era la sua mi cerca l'arma la
rotta
no non c'è niente qua dove può essere
perché qua se fosse qua dentro dentro la
piscina e tra di palline vediamo
buttiamo tripoli con i
ma mi faccia qualcosa
ma
è ora che cosa devo fare però
minuto
ok sarà prontissima ad affrontare agli
umani non fate riuscirà a sconfiggerlo
con queste due patrick oppure devo
sbrigarmi liberare evitare
vieni pure poste ne ha il coraggio dei
fronti vaghi a combattere contro l'itas
tori dove sei anni ma chi è si può
risalire il coraggio
eccolo non ho più paura di te anzi sei
pronto a combattere contro liga stati
beccati
abbiamo capito
e ha speso momento devo liberare vitale
abbiamo
un grande di te ce l'ha fatta
pronti poi
[Musica]
sono serviti così l'aspetto
grazie grazie
la legge
ricordo che stare pauroso scuola di
misteri e ora disponibile in libreria
lo avete ordinato fari spenti non potete
non averlo è un libro bellissimo con un
sacco di storie che vi terranno
incollati alle pagine in più
accumulerete tantissimi punti coraggio e
alla fine del libro scoprirete oa quale
profilo fatene decreti e il punto il
coraggio accumulati quindi prenderebbero
subito e ora vi lasciamo qualcosa per
salire se pubblicare per vedere i nostri
altri video vi cada su quella che
preferite